I'm over keeping up with this lifestyle
of crazy hair and wigs
Kylie Jenner just reveals what her real
hair looks like on Instagram and it's
super short on Monday the 22 year olds
hit up Instagram to share this clip
that's the beauty mogul rocking some
super short lighter tresses mid root
touch-up
Kylie's had her extra short bob since
February
courtesy of celeb stylists hey-zeus cool
yet oh she debuted the new do on
Instagram with the caption quote
hey-zeus hair said he was giving me a
trim and cut off all my hair but
hey-zeus was quick to assure his
followers that the cut was very much
requested writing kylie jenner is trying
to play me back in November Kylie gave
us another peek at her real hair sans
wig at the time she was sporting a
slightly longer lob that showed off her
natural deep brunette color as for those
bronze locks brunette blonde
it is super in with the
kardashian-jenner 's me and Chloe are
gonna do this at the end of the month
Chloe debuted an ultra blunt bronze lob
in February after asking her fans on
Instagram if she should commit to the
shade Kim also flirted with the color
for a hot set
Chloe
that they were gonna be mean in this
hair color god she recently posted these
clips of herself with flowing bronde
waves and Braund it's pretty mild for
Kylie I always try to be different I
always try to do new things I think my
following started to get a little bigger
when I really was just finding out like
my style and who I was and dyeing my
hair and like not everyone was like
dyeing their hair blue and green you
know people know I kind of just like to
what I want they just don't know what to
expect
she's been platinum blonde neon pink
dark green light green dark blue blue
light blue turquoise navy blue light
pink lavender orange gray and silver
just to name a few
oh and remember when she kept her blue
hair blue for Kim and Kanye West wedding
Kylie's hair is still blue and she
promised me she would put extensions in
to cover it it's just not worth the
battle and I'm just gonna let it go and
she has blue hair at my wedding and
while she still plays with color from
time to time for the most part she's
keeping it a little more natural these
days guys I don't want to disappoint
anybody but I just want my hair long and
boring
wanna be a weirdo I don't want to pull
up with purple hair I'm over it
[Music]